un but qui suffit au bonheur des
trappistes ce dimanche 16 décembre en
match en retard du championnat de
régionale 3 les rouges se sont imposés
dans des conditions climatiques
difficiles à domicile contre euro et
malmaison
score final 1 à 0 sentiment de victoire
logique et méritée même si on aurait pu
se rendre le match beaucoup plus facile
on n'a pas su concrétiser nos temps
forts on a une équipe de relais qui nous
a pas mal embêter on a su faire le dos
rond on n'a pas su profiter des espaces
qui nous offrait
pour rapport de force mais la finalité
c'est que on a su être solides ne pas
prendre de but et qu'on termine
meilleure défense du championnat avec
cette victoire les trappistes reste
invaincu et reprennent la première place
de la poule c de régionale 3 avec un
petit point d'avancé sur boulogne
billancourt le podium l'objectif fixé en
début de saison semble de plus en plus
accessible l'objectif est toujours le
même on est des compétiteurs et même si
normal que le président ils soient
tranquilles ils modèrent il tempère les
joueurs nous on n'a qu'un objectif c'est
de sets gagnés de gagner de gagner tous
les week-ends et de rendre à la fois le
staff tous les gens autour les
supporters qui viennent nombreux fiers
de nous et voilà c'est la première place
à l'est aussi pour eux en 2019 les
trappistes tenteront de garder cette
dynamique après la trêve hivernale pour
conserver la première place les joueurs
dit cham et redit se rendront sur le
terrain des mureaux le dimanche 20
janvier
leur résolution prolonger leur série
d'invincibilité qui affiche actuellement
dix matches sans défaite